you know what reborn means now i think
what does it mean i think it means
when when when they say someone is
reborn it always sounded like what
reborn what the heck is that
i think what it is is that
you have found your place god's here
and you're here or god's beside you he's
just a little bit bigger
god's you know he's always just a little
bit bigger than you he's inside you but
he's more than you are and
you're reborn you're reborn with
god before you know before it was you
self-will and then afterwards it's god's
will
you're reborn with god that's reborn
that's pretty it's not
it's not hokey pokey or anything it's
pretty
yeah you know i understand that does
everyone need to be reborn
or do some people because of their
upbringing they already see themselves
as minuscule compared to god so they
don't have that
rebirth yeah that with with a i think
maybe with a
a very careful spiritual
upbringing and luck
you can you can have that
but still you know the challenges of
life will be there and
for it to be an individual relationship
with god
you're given these problems that might
be generations old
to deal with meaning
like for example oh well things that may
have happened to your grandparents
are things that are still happening to
you until you
uh recognize them in your life
and then maybe you can heal them
what would be an example of that abuse
abuse yeah right abuse would be one
thing
so if somebody and then you know your
uh your grandfather and then and then
your one of your parents
and then your parents behavior and
that's
interesting you you have the same
behavior and then you get married and
you show the same behavior with your
spouse and then your children learn it
from you and it just goes on and on
until someone recognizes hey you know
what
this behavior this is troublesomeness
behavior i wonder where it came from
and why it's there and to accept it to
accept it as
necessary to bring you
to this understanding with your higher
power
okay that last part that's interesting
accept it as necessary can you please
expand on that
so if uh so i'm so say i'm recognizing
some
um way that i'm dealing with my
relationships that isn't working
and i'm recognizing that it's not
working and then i'm recognizing
i'm accepting that this is the way it's
been and that i've been
dealing with things for years this way
and that
that's the best i could do because
that's all i knew
so whatever happened in the past i can
say was there to bring me where i am
today
otherwise i wouldn't be here
right interesting interesting and then
you wouldn't be in this moment
you wouldn't be in this moment without
all of that no matter what it was
which is a very tough thing to come to
terms with sometimes because
whatever was in the past can be really
something that you
are not able to contend with but if you
see it as
necessary to bring you here and here
you are wanting to humble yourself
to god you wouldn't have got here
without that